bello di ragazze visiva questo nuove
idee sono fargelli e oggi siamo su un
titolo pazzesco naso che cola di sangue
giochi sono gasato come una scimmia di
giocare a sta roba raga perché era un
gioco che avevo giocato un po di tempo
fa in realtà qualche anno fa se non erro
semplicemente la una giornata questa
cosa è una demo sempre avanti
sono io
ad essere galasso ho detto no stanno ha
parlato di loro scusa ha messo stessa
parla con me scusa fate fate tradivo
rientro non lo so io vado avanti gli
spender st tv che mi sta dando fastidio
non so se poi da posti c'è la maniglia a
trovare per aprire il coso che è
bellissimo perché a tipo e'così di
amnesia ma posso girare ma cos'è posso
girare la televisione ma cosa serve
posso girare il televisore per farmi
luce praticamente ma che è madonna tema
chiave di che c'è qualcosa qua
il sony
take this sottile di won grab vedi che
ho trovato le cose perché adesso lo
picco qua intero piano per rappresentare
il leone cane fifone sarebbe bellissimo
se dicessero sta cosa la tv ma non lo
dicono il martello va bene non me ne
frega niente come sta dicendo non avere
vado a rio leccio io non sei suo figlio
il prete aveva ragione ha chiamato la
moglie il pride
ecco perché orco demonio lo sapevo me dr
ok ne vado arrivederci è stato ben
dunque stanno dialogando loro due
ragazzi cosa fossero in due da una parte
di un nuovo capitolo sì ma da questa
parte vada a finire esattamente dove c'è
il papa o nord è infatti prima che fanno
tiche porca [ __ ]
tutto a posto posso ci sono le candele
mar tutto ben i ragazzi tutto a posto in
casa non chiedo perché non mi sembra
proprio di no
se per te la porta
si è aperta questa porta
papa
scenica qua dentro
sono tornata al desktop ma vabbè che
bello allegro
tutto a posto va bene
così
ma che cazzo c'è un televisore dentro il
muro è un po scomodo guarda la tv così
poi non so poi alla ragazza sta luce che
luca 16 anni ma c'è la voce in
ottantenne mag mamma papà vi amo ok
la polaroid e come ha ricordato sta cosa
click to read camera rettile pro dove
prima equipaggiarlo ok ho un la posso
tirare fuori la camera così a bach che
succede niente ho fatto una buona
scattate una foto
devo
scorto la scatola lo scotto lo italiano
è cercato su di sé perché non lo sapete
voi ma veloso io ma le parole come
eccole
ma ci mettono ci mettono nel tempo a
renderizzare si le polaroid va bene ci
sarà scritto sicuramente sul muro da
qualche parte
ok lo posso fare una foto che non vedo
un gas
alla finestra post sima se continuiamo
così e
si sviluppa subito allora ok niente
c'era la foto
che non vedo non vedo non vedo non vedo
a posto non c'è niente minchiate ansa
non c'è niente che è successo o
no ragazzi sentono rumori non mi piace
per il culo ragazzi non mi piace per il
culo mi ammazzo ti ammazzo il successo
perché continua a sentire rumori di qua
perché si è avvicinato questa fare qual
è il problema abbiamo veramente non so
di che cacchio sempre
a chi the moon
boot destra murt mannaggia a te che tiri
fuori le le coperte da da dai cosi porco
le mangia non vedo poter esserci per
caso qualche entità oscura minchia sta
diventando paranormale suo gioco
no c'è solo lampadario sì ma io non
posso andare avanti a polaroid e non
vedo niente in tutto questo non penso
adesso posso fare perché prima non c'era
la luce va bene
ma devo trovare una specie di un chiodo
per appenderlo va bene e dove stava
prima ceramica al chiodo qualcosa
cerchio
allora se mi tirate su sto coso ancora
una volta chiamo l'impresa edile e vi
faccio cementare l'anno non lo so io lo
posso dire fuori tovaglie ogni 4 secondi
dunque jack nobile perché ogni tanto c'è
ogni tanto non c'è dentro va bene eccolo
st chiodo che ho trovato
ha fatto un rumore tipo di gomma ma va
bene
ok ok ok ok ok
la zia la zia
non c'è nessuno ha posto è entrata nel
muro questi sono tipo e il binario 9
trequarti di a riposo è più o meno la
stessa allora io stesso a ficcare il
chiodo
beh senza usare le mani sono più farà
normale io di voi il tuo gioco ragazzo
insieme ne siete accorti e poi piccolo
quadro
eccolo qua
perfetta e meno male perché è veramente
bello sulla meritavano e adesso devo
fare una foto al tizio dell'app della
polaroid non so se tu porca [ __ ]
della sorella morta ieri ma perché per
chiedo fast a vita io che
lo sa per quest'altro e non ho visto non
so cosa è successo non ho visto
ho fatto o sta la porta bene
la chiave usa la chiave ce n'è una
non lo so cosa stai facendo ma io non la
porta non era qui ma infatti non è che
entra nei proprio
d'accordo non si è capito un cazzo però
effettivamente è un gioco della bat mica
non vedo la chiesa sta per uscire tra le
mozioni sta per uscire questo gioco sta
veramente per uscire l'ansia è tremenda
c'è veramente incredibile credo che non
abbiano voluto svelare molto perché c'è
molto poco però è veramente figo signori
questa è la loro gli orchi spero che vi
sia piaciuto mi dispiace che sia durato
un po poco ma veramente merita
tantissimo sonda e meditano aspettiamo
che esca il gioco ufficiale niente come
se i ragazzi sono fiducioso e mi piace
anche la risorsa causa dell'estinzione
senso che se rischiate era come sempre
ci vediamo al prossimo video e da
ragazzi
[Musica]